[Musique]
oui bien la parole aux femmes si ses
médecins lui cette semaine j'aimerais
faire une chronique légère et à 80
printemps et fait beau mais je dois
réagir aux commentaires de pierre dufour
le ministre la mfp ministre des forêts
la faune du parc par rapport à son
commentaire sur les i nous et la chasse
au caribou je m'explique pour ce qui
suit faux activement le dos aussi du
caribou forestier
il ya un coup de sabre je suis très
impliquée par rapport à ça non seulement
parce que je suis une femme qui nous est
que ça le caribou je ne serais pas là
donc mon implication et une relation
avec le caribou est très très personnel
mais aussi à travers ma mission au
travail donc le caribou forestier comme
étant un des cheptels que dans des
chapelles les plus en danger ou sud du
québec
toutes les dossiers du caribou forestier
je pourrais en parler par rapport aux
actions plutôt à l'inaction de la cat
sur lequel il faut reste et on s'entend
que c'est quand même ce gouvernement pas
un job ne sera perdu pour le caribou
mais est ce que je veux faire c'est
mettre de côté un peu le caribou en
attendant mais ramener ça
sur les commentaires et ses commentaires
sont extrêmement problématique pour les
i nous mais pour aussi des doublés
nations confondues autochtone je
m'explique ses kilos pendant qu'il était
questionné
les actions que la cac a pris pour
protéger le caribou forestier justement
la mise en manque l'eau le fait que ces
projets là fonctionnent plus ou moins
haut un moment donné commencer à 10 ans
à pointer du doigt une communauté et
nous comme communauté de natashquan en
disant ouais mais là j'ai une communauté
autochtone dans l'est du québec qui a
détruit 10 % d'un cheptel de 500 têtes
puis le jeu mais ceux-là hockey
communauté ea nous dans l'est du québec
qui a détruit 10 % d'un cheptel de 500
têtes parce que les mots la banque sont
utilisés sont extrêmement extrêmement
problématique et je reviens expliquer
pourquoi excusez moi j'essaye de mettre
en place des choses et je veux être sûr
d'être juste dans mon analyse plus aussi
dans ma critique de ce qui a été dit
c'est pas un groupe de chasseurs de
trois rivières c'est pas un groupe de
chasseurs avec des gens qui peuvent
identifier à bhl c'est qu'on va avoir
des nouvelles c'est un groupe de
chasseurs autochtone
dans l'est du québec
qui a détruit détruit un orateur qu'ils
ont fait un massacre qu'ils ont
gaspillage un nom qui parce que nous on
va dire on ne soit cueilli où on a
chassé les caribous et j'explique
comment ces prix retrait à la légère
quand on dit chassez au kenya parce que
détruit un signe qu'on a gaspillé qu'on
n'a pas pris en compte qu'on a pas fait
attention
je tiens à dire que les chansons i nous
quand ils chassent pour tout ce que j'ai
vu dans ma jeunesse on s'entend qu'on
peut pas généraliser gmail mais pour
nous une chasse c'est une chose qui est
une chose de partage les gens vont
donner de la viande aux aînés à leur
famille un chauffard chasse rarement
pour uniquement lui-même et se partage
de cette chasse de ces la survie de la
communauté c'est la santé de la
communauté
et surtout quand aussi le prix l'avion
de transport de la viande
c'est notre chasse locale est une chasse
locale depuis des millénaires
millénaire vous comprendrez que si je
disais un québécois demain dimanche
[ __ ] je pense qu'on aurait une
réaction à ces instantanés et bien c'est
pareil pour les nounous on a diminué la
chasse même on est rendu à faire une job
condensé la viande interdire c'est parce
qu'on veut lui laisser le temps de se
remettre mais on est quand même là on
existe sur le territoire on regrette
avec ces pratiques là et on chasse mais
y'a pas un gaspillage
y'a rien qui va être perdu les pauvres
ont été utilisés d'autres vont être
utilisés parce que ça fait partie aussi
des activités de transmission
traditionnelle et je tiens à souligner
une chose extrêmement importante par
rapport au droit canadien un droit
ancestral doit être un droit continue
sexy tranquillement en interdisant ou en
facilitant justement l'art et la chasse
pour lézignan et bien tranquillement ses
droits de chasseurs vont disparaître ici
ça ne sera plus un droit continuer
tranquillement ses des droits ancestraux
qui vont disparaître et je dis pas qu'on
chasse pour le droit ancestral mais je
dis juste qu'il y en a pour qui ce
serait vraiment avantageux qu'on arrête
de le faire parce que ce serait des
droits qui tranquillement disparaître
mais là je reviens au fait que c'est un
droit présentant alimentaire notre santé
les aînés qui ont jamais manger presque
de viande qui viennent pas du bourg tout
ça s'est pointé du doigt quand on
division qu'ils ont dû chasser le
caribou
alors que aller méthane enclos main
permettant une forêt sphérique qui va
encore du rejet du territoire au caribou
nous on protège les loges explique
qu'une chose que je sais tellement de
mettre dans la tête des gens les gens
qui mangent le caribou village inclut
les chasseurs québécois j'inclus les i
nous tous ceux qui sont impliqués dans
le territoire dans la chasse ce sont la
majorité de temps ce que je vois qui
sont les plus grands protecteurs du
caribou qui vont se mettre en réflexion
de kéroul qu'ils vont trouver des
solutions parce que ça veut dire la
survie de la vie alors que ceux qui
n'ont jamais mis à mort ceux des rivaux
dans leur bouche ou n'ont jamais porté
du caribou eux pour eux ça fait mais que
le caribou meurt en silence
tranquillement dans un enclos votre plus
servir à leurs besoins qui sont ceux de
manger de la nourriture et de l'argent
les inouk qui vont manger de caribous
ont même pensé de le protéger parce que
son cours des parts dans ce cas allez
vous depuis des milliers
le problème c'est en essayant
d'expliquer la chasse traditionnelle
importance du rôle pourquoi ces on
montre justement comment le
discrimination systémique dans les
changements climatiques la
projets d'extraction wismes de coupes
forestières de barrages hydro
électriques
commencent à arriver dans les
communautés et là on va voir parce qu on
a fait tous ces projets là au québec
pour gagner de l'argent pour avoir des
fonds et bien présentement sa protéine
ou dans un recoin et dansera coin alors
ils essayent d'être in où il essaie de
faire leurs activités traditionnelles
et parce que justement les impacts
négatifs qui vient de ces projets là que
j ai nommé commencent à arriver là et on
voit on commence à les voir bien si les
problématiques sont ce territoire en
train d'essayer de manger ou c'est ce
qui continue de faire des projets
continuent d'ignorer la problématique
vous trouvez des fausses solutions pour
pouvoir continuer de faire ça et de
pousser jusqu'au ras coin les unit les
guerres goût la forêt la survie des
populations parce que ce l'on voit en
premier les communautés autochtones
après ça va des communautés pauvres et
au mode et racisées et vous allez voir
que pointer du doigt va devenir plus
facile mais j'ai dit à monsieur dufour
qui devrait présenter des excuses
officielles pour ce commentaire parce
que ça reflète justement toute
l'histoire coloniale du canada de dire
que les autochtones sont le problème sur
le territoire c'est ce qui a fait qu'on
les a enlevées les crises qui étaient
commis dans des pensionnats c'est ce qui
a fait qu'on nous a envoyés dans les
écoles de jour c'est ce qu'a fait toni
dans les réserves parce qu'on était sur
le terrain on était le problème est là
maintenant qu'on peut plus nous mettre
dans ces institutions là dans ses
réserves de dire qu'on est sur le
territoire ont existé comme angers
converse avec le plus minime homme
n'aime pas qu'on peut essayer d'avoir et
qu'on est encore le problème vous
comprendrez monsieur qu'il faut pour que
la madame n'était pas contente quand
vous entendre
j'espère que vous comprendrez
les problématiques et en 2022 en
entendant ce genre de commentaire là
peut venir faire réagir différemment
une personne qui vient de ma nation et
comment ça continue de nourrir et de
permettre justement aux communautés
québécoises qui trouve déjà que les
communautés attaques informatiques mais
ça commence à nourrir leurs critiques ça
commence à devenir oui c'est les
autochtones qui ont trop chasse et si on
avait trop celle ci on serait pas là
quand vous êtes arrivé
on a su quand même que notre vie nos
dépendances et je pense qu'elle avons
aussi des parts que de cette refonte est
que la forêt doivent rendre cette santé
que terrible doit avoir parce que kerry
bourg est centrale dans une forêt ans
est entré en tout cas je dis ça je dis
ça avec beaucoup de passion mais aussi
avec beaucoup de
crainte parce que on le situe souvent
montrent souvent comme seulement quand
tout le dernier poisson voir été pêché
que la dernière rigueur bayrou était
pour lui que ce dernier qui arrive ou va
aurait été mis en en cloud vient
seulement là on va se rendre compte que
l'argent ne se mange pas alors merci
beaucoup pour votre écoute je vous
souhaite une bonne semaine j'espère que
vous allez partager cette vidéo je fais
aussi vous allez nous envoyer des
suggestions et si jamais vous cherchez
des sujets légers que vous aimeriez en
attendant il sait pas me les envoyer
j'aime bien des pros changer un petit
peu le topo du canada bonne semaine